my poop runs in
so you just run in how you just come in
when you want to yeah
yeah she was getting in trouble just now
she was out on the porch and
where you open the door to let her in
and she like runs past you really fast
yeah
which means she got time i have
something in my mouth and i don't want
anybody
she had a big old lizard with a tail
that had partly partly grown back
i caught it put it back outside but
because the tail was missing and grown
back it was one of her repeat customers
he he was kind of chilled about i
chilled out about it he was like yeah
this happens quite a bit he caught
and that big two-legged hit you and it
lets you go
he didn't really avoid me he's like yeah
this will let me go
yeah i guess so yeah he's like yeah the
little grey monster gets me
yeah and then this one and then the
bigger flesh-colored monster comes and
yeah
it takes me out of the great monster's
mouth yeah
poor lizard yeah he didn't really fight
too much she's just like yeah
i like the way she tries to sneak them
into the house though like she thinks
she's being all sly because she's like
what i don't know if i don't have
anything and she like runs past you
really quick once they get beyond a
certain size she doesn't kill them i
guess because they're
they can take the beating yeah yeah i
mean but i find a little dead once that
that she kills by accident they do they
can't put
yeah because she's little bones you know
she does this to kill them she just just
wants to play with them
but it kills them yeah when they're
little because she's like
yeah so we're gonna do a spoiler free
review
on this one's called relic yes it's an
australian flick
this is a brand new australian horror
movie just premiered i think it's
sundance
uh in january of this year and it just
dropped on the uh
on various streaming platforms just a
couple weeks ago i think on july 3rd
and i'd actually been hearing a lot
about this one there's kind of like a
lot of buzz about it coming out of
sundance
and uh this was actually the directorial
debut of a woman named natalie erica
james uh also a
australian filmmaker yeah and uh it has
it was bothering me because one of the
main characters in it there's not a lot
of uh
you know characters and it's really a
three character piece
um but the mom in it is played by emily
mortimer and the whole time
damn it i know i've seen i mean she's
been in a ton of [ __ ] i know but i was
like man we just saw her in something
recently what was that and it was
no it was um mary poppins returns of all
things
okay and that was the most recent thing
that we've saw that she was in
oh maybe she's one of the older biker
woman no no no no i'm not talking about
the older woman i'm talking about the
the middle ages oh the middle aged one
yeah yeah because she looked like super
super familiar
um but yeah so basically this
movie it's gonna be okay like
it reminded me of a lot of movies it
reminded me
of the taking of deborah logan um
even though that's found footage or my
mockumentary and this one's not this
one's just like kind of
just a straightforward horror movie but
in the sense that
um the dementia could be dementia could
be
supernatural kind of thing it had that
kind of vibe to it
um reminded me a little bit of
oculus um the babadook
a little bit yeah um had a little bit
uh in parts had a little bit of a house
of leaves thing that's not a movie
that's a book
but um just in the sense of a
strange geometry or like strange uh
you know like a house that's bigger on
the inside or the outside you know they
had that was a little
aspect of that as well um so this was
kind of like
i actually really really liked this
movie it was um it's pretty like
low-key it's not there's no big jump
scares there's nothing like that
but there's like some really nice like
creepy
kind of imagery and i think it did a
good job of like kind of just building
up it had like a really cool like
atmosphere about it like a dread kind of
atmosphere to it
and as i said it's you know the the
setting that they used with the house
and
the fact that there's pretty much only
three characters there's a couple other
like there's a you know a guy that lives
next door that's kind of factors in a
couple of minutes
but most of it is just these three
characters these three women
and so i think it had like this really
nice kind of claustrophobic
type of thing now that said if you don't
like because it is kind of
it's like i said i don't want to spoil
it but it is kind of like a more
symbolic type of horror movie
kind of like the babadook was so if that
sounds like something that's going to
make you mad then probably you won't
like it
yeah but i really dug it i thought it
was pretty cool i don't think it was
like fantastic or anything i probably
liked the babadook better
um and i liked oculus better but it but
this movie is kind of in the same
line as that like in the same genre as
that i thought it was a well-made movie
but i also thought it was kind of saney
there's a lot of movies like this there
are yeah it's it's well made it's
australian
it's just uh i enjoyed watching it it's
just that uh
nothing really to me really stood out
about it there's a lot of movies like
this
it just seems like another one yeah you
know it's a good one
yeah it's better than watching a bad
movie yeah it's just
i think maybe if i was younger i'd
[ __ ] would have enjoyed it more
i mean i've seen so many movies and
[ __ ] scenes you know
they're they all kind of are the same uh
these type of horror movies now
just if you ask me they seem to be the
same well a lot of them are similar like
i said there's
you know and i think some people too are
trying to replicate the success
of uh you know some movies you know
particularly in this case like i said
the babadook which was also an
australian
movie um everything's been done it's
hard not to
it is it's really hard not to been done
already
yeah because you don't want to you don't
want to make something so
out there that you're going to you know
turn people off
because it's so it's too weird or
doesn't make sense or whatever
but then again you don't want to make
something so generic that people just
like forget about it and that's kind of
like a hard
it's like a difficult thing to do i
guess because as you said you know
everything's been done
visually it looked good the acting was
good you know
the edit was was good it it tries to do
kind of like uh what you'd call like a
slow burn and i'd say
successful at that yeah it does kind of
ramp it up to some weird [ __ ] that
happens
um so you i can't fault it for that i
can only fault really at this point
i can only fault the damn genre the
genre's been around so long that
everything's been done already
yeah that's really where the problem is
i mean
you could argue that things had been
done like way before that because
you can always find like example like
older that's what i'm saying that's what
i'm saying maybe it's my age
yeah maybe a younger person would enjoy
it a lot more because you know they're
not as familiar with this
with these motifs and stuff yeah you
know but
i i really don't think they make movies
for people in their 40s and 50s i think
they really are making it
for people more in their early 20s
teenagers and
in their 20s i think that's who they
think is going to come to the theaters
yeah maybe not so much nowadays nowadays
but that's originally what it was
i think well yeah i do feel like and i
mean that's even going back to [ __ ]
that's even going back to the 50s really
um
is that you you know younger people were
actually maybe even longer ago than that
because
30s 20s yeah because that's what like
kids they didn't have tv so you know
you'd give them a quarter and they'd go
like watch all the movies all day long
people forget how old theater is
or how cinema cinema is very old
yeah it is a it is an out of date format
i mean it's going to be it's being
replaced with streaming yeah
yeah that's just way too well and like i
said that's what ended up this one you
know
premiered at sundance and you know got a
little bit of a buzz about it
and then um you know the streaming
platforms picked it up and you know they
started showing it this summer the
australian
uh streaming service they have one
called stan which i think is very funny
uh but it premiered on there and we
actually did we rent it on xbox i think
we rented it on next yeah i read this on
the xbox
yeah and i think it's uh you can run it
on youtube you can run it like other
places too it might be on amazon prime
as well but um did we even say like okay
so this is what the movie is about
there is uh a woman named kay and she
has a
daughter who's like in her twenties uh
named sam
now they have heard that kaye's mother
edna
has not been seen she lives alone like
kind of out in the
you know not really the woods but you
know what i mean kind of out in the
suburbs or in the rural area and the
neighbors have said that you know we
haven't seen her around in a little
while so maybe you want to come and like
check
because she's an older woman and they
think maybe she's losing her marbles or
whatever
so the mom and the daughter go out there
and weirdly
when they get there they can't find edna
anywhere
she's not anywhere in the house um you
know and then there's
like kind of mold all over the fruit in
there suggesting she hasn't
she's been gone a long time and so
you know they're kind of looking around
they ask the neighbors and everything
and they can't find anything and then
finally they go to the police and report
her missing
and then after a couple of days edna
shows back up
but won't tell them where she was or
what she was doing
and it seems to get kind of pissed off
at them when they ask her about it
um and then like things start to
ramp up where you know you get like kind
of weird noises in the house
some shadowy kind of things going on and
you're not
really entirely sure and then like kay
starts having this recurring dream about
this old cabin that used to be on the
property
and um that was the best part of this
movie is that yes it's them
talking about this old cabin on this
property one time was an old cabin
that somebody's dad was in it was her
great it was her great great great
grandfather that's right
and nobody he wasn't really being taken
care of properly when he was real old he
was just kind of left out there and he
died out there
it wasn't dead in that cabin for a long
time before they came and got him
and and they keep showing back to this
damn cabin and the body rotten in the
cabin and that
that part stuck out to me yeah the
imagery on that one was very effective
yeah i thought yeah i really liked that
um
like i said the movie unfolds a bunch of
paranormal stuff can't spoil everything
about it
um it is a good movie yeah it's um
it's just really what really wasn't for
me yeah i mean but i i can understand
why other people might like it
and i really like that i really kind of
like the way
one thing i liked was that everything
tied together like you have this thing
about this [ __ ] that had happened in the
past with her great grandfather and him
dying out there kind of alone because
no one had been watching him yeah and
then
you get the feeling i mean that's kind
of the whole theme of the movie
um and why it's called relic which could
mean like the
you know the cabin out there what it
could mean edna herself people
yeah when they're like forgotten and
they just are left out there of to their
own device
to me for me the theme was basically of
it was about abandoning the old
and just about aging and decay in
general bodily decay
yeah and um what happens when you
abandon the old it's like
it's kind of like a the movie's going to
kind of
let it be known that that the movie is
going to portray abandoning the old
as a very subtle form of evil that's how
that's how i picked
it yeah yeah that it's like an ancient
evil sin
that people do yeah that just kind of
like continues
like it's a cycle yeah that they forget
about their grandparents and their
great-grandparents and they died
oh well yeah and then it just and then
it
kind of comes back to haunt yeah right
but it's also like that part
it's also kind of saying too that it's
that aging and decay is inevitable and
like in the sense that it happens to
everybody
yeah i mean the last like i said i'm not
going to spoil it but the last shot
really kind of hammered that home yeah
um that it was going to continue
you're trying to play on the dread that
your time is coming too
yeah which like i said that's i think
that's one of the best things about it
is this atmosphere of dread that kind of
infuses the whole thing
and it's kind of like it's a creepy
movie but it's also like a
sad movie you know what i mean it's
really sad um
it might be a little bit of hereditary
too although i didn't like it as much as
hereditary because i loved hereditary
but um you know
along that line what's funny though in
my opinion my experience that's how good
old people die
evil old people they die surrounded by a
bunch of people taking care of them
that's what usually happens i know
that's shitty
i know i know it's terrible they're not
alone yeah and that's
yeah yeah they're not alone and [ __ ]
they got people [ __ ] waiting on them
and
oh it's gonna be okay filming full of
[ __ ] everybody knows that they're going
to die and they just say yeah yeah
they're talking about men and then
they're dead a few hours later
there's no justice in the world not
really no
and then somewhere else out in some
neighborhood you know what i mean
[ __ ] woman falls over breaks her hook
hip gets wedged in between a piece of
damn furniture and dies of thirst out
there in her house
yeah we were talking about talking about
that we were talking about that all
right
all her cats died they couldn't get out
of the house she laid up in there for
about eight years before they found the
body
because she owned the house they didn't
find her body until we're going to tear
the house down
i told you that when uh when i used to
live with my grandma
the man next door died in the house
uh just sitting in his chair and um
he was in there for several days before
anybody found him and i mean it's
because i
i came outside my grandma was outside
she's like jenny jenny come out here
there's a hearse and everything and i
was like
what so we came out there and they said
yeah he was just sitting there in the
chair
he's been there like a while that's
usually how dudes go out though
they're sitting there and all of a
sudden just [ __ ] heart attack boom or
stroke boom that's it
just sitting there watching sitting here
whatever like eating some cheetos that's
how my dad's dad died he was [ __ ] he
was young he was only 42 years old he
must have had some kind of defective
heart
he was [ __ ] cheering on some dude
boxing on television
he was [ __ ] i don't know my dad knew
who it was he was rooting for some dude
watching the fights game game getting on
his [ __ ] throne then he goes
oh i don't feel too good and then boom i
was out that was it
huh yeah and he was like 42 45 i mean i
guess if you got to go
that's probably the best way to go
because he probably didn't even know
what happened to him and he seemed like
he was having a f having a good
time yeah yeah he was yeah yeah he's all
right
he was young that's crazy like 42 or 43
he must have had some kind of defective
heart
yeah because that's very unusual he
wasn't overweight or anything you know
he was my build
yeah well because sometimes if you have
like little i know this is terrifying
but sometimes if you have like little
like a hole in your heart or in the
aorta or something like that like it's
too small to
yeah notice but it's like it's just kind
of like a ticking time bomb
it was back in the 50s you know they
didn't really help tight
back in the 50s in mississippi he
probably never had an x-ray or anything
yeah and i mean if you don't really have
any outward symptoms and there's no
reason to go get checked on
no he seemed normal yeah he seemed
healthy somebody said reminds me of a
rose for emily yeah it it it did kind of
remind me of that a little bit as well
that story but um i was gonna say too
my grandfather he just had he
he lived by himself as well and he just
had a um
uh what do you call that like a brain
hemorrhage they said that's because
yeah evil people just like that in there
evil people surround die surrounded by
people because you're right they're all
waiting for their money
well yeah everybody's like they got
you're money people bad their whole
[ __ ] life and then all of a sudden
people are coming up oh it's
you know [ __ ] kissing around kissing
their asses
but yeah oh another thing that i really
liked about this movie too that i wanted
to mention
is that there were because i've gotten
to a point now where
especially after kind of all the
offshoot conjuring movies like the non
and everything
dude said he read the dudes the big nuts
[ __ ] get have
are more prone to heart attacks really
i've never heard that i wonder if
there's some kind of correlation i think
he's [ __ ]
well it's very possible that it could be
a correlation so i don't do guys a heart
attack to go come here
bring him over here let's measure his
balls for our study where's his
ball measurement let me get a cast of
them balls we're gonna put those with
the rest up we're gonna hang them on the
back of the pickup truck
well yeah is that really something that
they
would measure like on like when they
were doing an autopsy or a dead body i
don't know it's like that seems like
not something that you would immediately
jump to
like measuring the balls but yeah so
what i was saying was that
you know especially you know movies that
came out kind of
in the you know that were kind of
conjuring ripoffs or even like in the
extended
conjuring universe um it really does
seem like
everything is jump scares
um and it gets to a point where it's
just
annoying this movie i liked that they
didn't do that and there were a couple
of times where you thought that they
were going to do that
but they didn't do it now that you
mention it this movie looks like a
conjuring movie it doesn't have like you
said
a lot of the gimmicks yeah it's not
gimmicky but
visually it does kind of look like a
conjuring movie it does a bit yeah
oh that's not bad that's good yeah just
in the sense that it has that
muted uh kind of aqua colors
palette and like with all the the black
kind of
mold and stuff because the mold is like
kind of a big uh
thing in there which actually now that
i'm thinking about it kind of reminded
me too of another
movie um i am the pretty thing that
lives in the house which also had a
thing with
mold and ghosts and kind of
you know uh yeah identity like
overlapping identity this is
a ghost movie i guess it could well
the thing about it is it's a ghost movie
it could be read either way
you could read it as a metaphorical
story
yeah um or you could read it as a
supernatural
or both it really works as both things
it's a ghost movie
kind of like in the way that high plains
drifter is a ghost movie
yeah which it that sounds off the wall
but i get what you're i get what you're
like a
revenant story i guess sort of yeah
yeah maybe it's possession we're not
really sure that's what i mean you could
read it that way
um or you could just read it like as a
straight up metaphor like the babadook
is
yeah um so that's why i think you know
it's good because i think it works
in either way because you know you could
argue that some of the [ __ ] that happens
in it like i said the
the sort of house of leaves direction it
goes in like in the third act like with
the
weird rooms and you know the girl can't
get out and everything
um you could argue that that was
actually happening and that that wasn't
just like a symbolic manifestation of
um you know the of edna's deteriorating
mental state but you could read it that
way too
so i just think that's cool because it
seems like it's you know it has like
double layers like double meaning
um so yeah it's this is a perfectly good
like i said any of the movies that i
compared it to
um if you dug any of those movies then
you'll probably like this one as well
like i said i don't think that it's
quite as good as those
um i would i think i liked this as much
as i liked oculus
you know what i mean i haven't seen
oculus in a few years but i remember
liking this one and that one about the
same
um you know i didn't like it as much as
the babadook or hereditary or anything
but it
but it's along those lines so if that
sounds like something that
would be something that you're into then
by all means check it out
um you know like i said it's the this
woman that uh
that directed it this is her first one i
see it's about like one of the conjuring
movies
i liked it better than the last few
conjuring movies we saw
the weird thing about it and i don't
know if i've ever mentioned this before
but
the conjuring the first conjuring
is a good movie but i don't get
why it turns up on so many best horror
movie lists
i thought it was okay i liked la llorona
yeah it was all right that had some
creepy imagery in it
and we were in there with a bunch of
[ __ ] teenagers and that [ __ ]
skinny ass mexican boy kept [ __ ]
screaming
[Laughter]
and then he didn't try to play it off
like he didn't scream yeah it's like
dude we all
we're all right yeah he's like about 16
or 17
probably weighed about 110 pounds trying
to be tough as [ __ ]
trying to play it off to his friends and
[ __ ] nah i'm just kidding i was just
kidding i hear him back there here
i'm just kidding i didn't really scream
yeah [ __ ] you were screaming
people were like and it was like he was
doing it during the during remember
during the build
up to the jump scare when you know the
jump scare is going to happen
he'd scream about [ __ ] three seconds
before everybody else
he couldn't take the stress
yeah yeah and he had a thick kind of
mexican accent [ __ ] that that [ __ ]
score that [ __ ] scared him
that's very funny but he's i was kind of
living vicariously through him though
you know what i mean because [ __ ]
like
i hadn't been scared in a movie in a
long time it's kind of it's kind of
funny to see
yeah like you know like yeah i used to
get that that scared that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] alien one
you know but i always try to i mean you
know being a horror movie fan
and you know yes once you get older it's
not quite the same yes
but i always try to put myself back in
that in those days
because it's like i want i mean if
you're watching a horror movie
i want to like surrender myself to it i
want it to scare me you know what i mean
that's what it's for
so it's like so i really do try to get
invested in them
i'm not one of those people who's like
oh you're horn baby they never scare me
because you're not like allowing
yourself to get sucked in it's hard
though when you get older
it is harder but i do like to try to do
that because like i said if you're not
impressionable you're more
impressionable and you haven't seen
you haven't seen all the tricks yet that
yeah that that film does
yeah and he was falling for every one of
them and i was up there in front of a
[ __ ]
giggling and [ __ ] i turn around and look
at him you know see who it was
you remember that kid yeah that's
vaguely i don't remember what he looked
like but yeah
just a little skinny masking guy that's
really funny yeah
i don't remember like i remember liking
la llorona more than the nun
yeah but i remember seeing that the
silhouette and the way they were making
that
la rona ghost move yeah
um it it was disturbing it was very
disturbing
it would come out of walls yeah and
there was something that they
did they showed it for too long and then
i lost my fear of it
see a lot of horror movies make that
exact
same mistake yeah they eat it they
showed it for too long and up close its
face and i and i was like oh
okay that's i see that at the club
it's a girl in in a in makeup they
shouldn't have never really counts it
you know they should have never really
shown it that clearly i really got
into this and this has been a discussion
going back to [ __ ]
i mean a lot of people talk about it in
regards to like jaws
and how the fact that their mechanical
shark wasn't working properly
it worked in the movie's favor because
they couldn't show the shark as much
which consequently made it scarier
because
if you had seen a whole bunch of it and
it was clearly a mechanical shark
obviously it's not going to be as
frightening because it looks fake
but i'm always kind of the person like i
don't want to be one of those people
because i remember reading uh
in stephen king's dance macabre and he
kind of went into this a little bit too
like is it better to
never show your monster or just show
parts of the monster
or just show the monster like
immediately um
and just kind of get it out of the way
first whereas i have always kind of
thought
i'll show it clearly and don't show it
close up yeah i kind of feel like it's
better to
leave a lot to the audience's
imagination i mean
that can be done badly whereas like some
where you watch a movie and like they
just don't show anything and it's not
clear enough to see what's going on and
yeah i can see that pissing some people
off but if it's done effectively i think
it's way
scarier see when they were first showing
the damn lot
like your own it was mostly just a
silhouette you can barely see it
yeah and it would come out of walls and
it would be that was very effective
yeah when they showed it clearly at its
face clearly and i think it spoke didn't
it
did it talk i don't even remember and
once i saw it i was like i went uh okay
they should have never showed it that
clearly they yeah they shouldn't have
showed it that much in that clearly
right it should only come well they were
trying to do something like they did
with
uh the lack or whatever the [ __ ] nuns
name is
because you know that image of herb has
been so iconic
but honestly even the earlier movies
that had the nun in them
were scarier when you couldn't quite see
her yeah like when she was just in the
background and [ __ ]
i mean one of my favorite things and one
of the reasons why hereditary was my
favorite movies of the last few years
was because they specifically i mean
there was those [ __ ] great scenes
where like you know
tony collette is like up on the ceiling
but they didn't
if you weren't looking up there you
wouldn't see it
you know what i mean like they really
they didn't put [ __ ] in your face they
didn't do
they just had all this [ __ ] going on in
the background and they didn't call
attention to it
uh they did the same thing in uh
haunting of hill house you know on
netflix
where there was like always little like
there was faces and there was just all
this [ __ ] and you couldn't even catch
all of it because they were
trying to do it subtly midwest outlaw
tried to post a link to the proof that
if you have bigger balls you get harder
all right
reminded me of you know the uh here at
disney world that
the haunted house where they have that
[ __ ] ghost to that damn
woman going [ __ ] you know until death
do us part all that kind of [ __ ] yeah
we had a friend who worked on that ride
he was a mechanic and he worked on that
ride
and he told me how they made that
[ __ ] ghost
and i was like really that's what it was
i forgot what it was how it was done
though that [ __ ] was [ __ ] weird
when you're in that buggy and you see
that thing
it looks like a three-dimensional they
do a lot of
mirrors yeah it looks like a
three-dimensional
semi-transparent moving [ __ ] figure i
mean it's
very [ __ ] convincing and you go buy
it so you're seeing it in 3d it looks
like a hologram
it's not though it's an optical illusion
like i said they do it with mirrors
they've been doing that at like circuses
and stuff like that for
like a century yeah it was very um
it was a mixture of a bunch of stuff it
was a you were seeing a reflection on a
piece of
glass mixed with something having to do
with
oh [ __ ] what was it nylon or something a
stretched out knife yeah like
cheesecloth yeah
and it looked like a dab
three-dimensional semi-transparent
glowing [ __ ] woman you could see
right through her
shoes face [ __ ] transforming and
you could see her heart beating in there
and she had a dab pulled out of the axe
and the axe went
[ __ ] remember that yeah that big shine
like that like [ __ ] the weirdest i think
they took it out i think they said
that the kids thought it was too scary
well the weird thing about that
was that see i don't remember because i
have been the haunted mansion at disney
world here in central florida like a
million times and i don't ever remember
that being there i think that was a
disneyland thing
um i don't know they might have added it
at disney world
i saw it and i've seen it on um well
no i'm just saying that they might have
added it subsequently oh okay i'm just
saying that the last time i was at
disney world
it was [ __ ] years ago i don't
remember somebody it wasn't there
somebody
snuck their phone in there and there had
have compiled many minutes of it
yeah i've seen it i was just telling you
that
when i when i was growing up she has a
name last time yeah and then like
last time i went to disney world it
wasn't there so that must have been a
newer addition
yeah she's talking about all the
husbands that she killed she said
matrimonial [ __ ] like until death do us
part and she pulls the axe out and
it [ __ ] gleams and then she says a
bunch of weird stuff you know what i
mean [ __ ]
do you think she's counting off one two
and just
and then around there they're all these
dead husbands
yeah she's talking about all the [ __ ]
day and you're going through the attic
and she's up in the attic and there's
all these [ __ ] old pictures of her
with all these
different dudes and they're like she's
like belgium when you look at when you
look at the picture he's there
one minute not all said his head's
vanished yeah and she's got an axe and
then the next one
it was like [ __ ] he's poisoned you
know all these dudes that she had killed
she's a black widow i love the haunted
mansion yeah all that [ __ ] 1800 [ __ ]
when i was a kid i wanted to live in
there i wish they'd make it a little
more scary
yeah you know there are parts of it that
were when i was a kid
but still quite fun the last time i went
through it yeah i haven't been on it
it had some ominous probably 10 years at
least
maybe longer when i was a kid that was
my favorite one and snow white and then
space mountain
yeah those were really good and i liked
the thunder mountain railroad
peter pan you're in that damn yeah
you're flying over to the [ __ ] model
city
you know what was weird when i was a kid
that snow white ride scared me more than
the hundreds yeah
which [ __ ] witch popping on your face
screaming yeah jesus
christ yeah i was like [ __ ] was loud
it was and i was just like oh someone
just no the voyage to the bottom of the
sea
yeah yeah i love that one yeah they
don't they don't have that anymore
well i like i said i think a lot of
people don't even like kids nowadays
wouldn't even [ __ ] remember that
[ __ ] movie
they're trying to like keep stuff
updated and i don't know i haven't been
yeah the pepper's ghost effect that's
what it's called if he's i have a book
over there on my shelves joe nichols
secrets of the sideshows
and he's got diagrams in there of how
they do that
effect because they've been doing that
at circuses for
like since the 19th end of the 19th
century at least
i i went by it many times because i
wrote it i rode that [ __ ] ride many
times that day and tried to figure out
what it was i was looking at
yeah that's probably a combination of
mirrors and projection
yeah it was like i couldn't figure it
out it looked like it was really there
but it's not
yeah or you know it's not there
it looks like mirrors if you you know
angling them toward each other
what's weird is that you're seeing it
you're seeing it from the front when you
first see it but you're in the buggy you
pass it you see it from the side
yeah so you know what i mean it's not
it's a 3d
illusion right because you're looking at
it from the side when you go by it yeah
but you can still see through it so i
don't know
how it's done although that guy that i'm
telling you about i can't remember
i'm not going to say his name i don't
want to he told me how it was done i was
like oh of course
it was like real simple yeah when it's
it's kind of the thing where like i said
when i was looking at the diagrams of
the pepper's ghost illusion
it's like when you're looking at it it
looks amazing but when you see a diagram
of how they do it you're like oh
obviously
right you know what i mean it seems
really easy it's just nothing you would
think of
just offhand yeah somebody asked who is
the old lady in the crystal ball at the
haunted mansion
i always thought it was phyllis diller
it kind of looks like her yeah i think
if not though it was something
it was an actress i didn't think that
was her yeah that didn't sound like
phyllis stiller's voice
that that would have been really funny
if that was phyllis yes
[Laughter]
she says as you go around the [ __ ]
crystal ball i think
i think there may be more one might have
been more than one i think they were
it was updated a couple times but the
original one i remember as a kid it
looked like phyllis diller
and the well and like i said the you
know disneyland
was built before disney world yeah um
so ours is slightly different i've been
to both of them
i've never been to the one in california
yeah but i've been to the one here in
orlando obviously like
zillions the haunted house felt a lot
older
okay yeah it looks dingier and it looks
more like an abandoned house
the one they have here it almost kind of
looks like it's in too good a condition
yeah you know even though as far as i
know it was built in 1971 or 1972. i'm
talking about
on the ride on the ride when you're on
the ride and going through it it looks a
lot older and a lot more threadbare
it looks more authentic yeah it looks
like you're in a real
um like a real a real victorian mansion
yeah
the one here has kind of a cartoon
element to it you can tell the stuff's
not that old
yeah yeah carpeting and stuff yeah um
this you know it looks like something
out of the monsters you know the
monster's house yeah looks what it
looked like
uh i think the layout was a little bit
different
and when you leave the house and go out
into the graveyard the graveyard's a lot
bigger
yeah because the graveyard at ours is
kind of small yeah the graveyard's a lot
bigger and you
you're convinced that you're outside
yeah
you know but you're not but they do a
really good job and then where
uh there's a couple little rooms that
were missing
out of the the orlando one there was one
where
it was a little it was like a room in
between a room it was like to give you
kind of like a sensation of [ __ ]
going from one environment to another
yeah and it was a huge spider web with a
[ __ ] gigantic spider about six feet
across
up in a corner and that isn't in the
orlando yeah that's not in ours i don't
know gigantic [ __ ] looks like a damn
banana spider or something
i think i remember there are some big
spiders like in the
graveyard bit yeah but i don't no
there's one part where you're in a big
just a big empty black room with a
gigantic web in it and there's a [ __ ]
update yeah i don't wanna have that up
in the corner is a [ __ ] spider about
six feet across
i mean it's been a while since i've been
on the haunted house here and i think
they've added some [ __ ] to it since the
last time i was there
somebody was asking what the cover
charge was like what it cost to get into
disney nowadays oh it's about
at least 100. i think it's getting up
there because i think even last time i
looked which was several years ago was
85
or something like that it's like a
ridiculous it's not worth it which like
i said you know what i wouldn't mind
paying that
if you could eat for free all day inside
the park it's like if you didn't have to
pay but
you know you go in and then the
restaurants and everything are
overpriced too
yeah so if if they just let you like eat
whatever you wanted
and go with all the rides and most most
of the park looks like [ __ ]
and and like you go through the jungle
ride and the signs that you go through
underground
you see signs and it's obviously just
cheap plywood with [ __ ] sequins
nailed to it it looks it looks like crap
most of it
it's very outdated i mean they're
updating stuff but it's really slow
yeah and then like the animals coming up
out of the water were all faded in the
florida sun
you can tell it's just a [ __ ] rubber
animatronic and all the [ __ ] paints
faded on
they look like crap uh for the same
amount of money you could go to a
universal and it's 20 times the theme
park
universal is much better yeah i think
disney really does suffer like in
comparison to universities
that harry potter [ __ ] visual [ __ ]
vr ride the
virtual reality ride [ __ ] awesome uh
the roller coasters are really good
just disney's what you'd take a little
kid to
yeah it still has that you know little
kid kind of
magic but it is a lot more geared toward
way younger
children and foreigners you know well
just to say that you've gone there i
mean really like the haunted mansion's
awesome
uh you know space mountain's still
pretty awesome um
you know some of the like uh splash
mountains fawn
you're gonna have all this [ __ ] merch
all this [ __ ] disney merch
the [ __ ] hotels [ __ ] it's it's
overpriced
if you ask me yeah and shady shit's
happened there over the years
yeah yeah i mean i used to have a like i
said we don't you know when i was
growing up we didn't have a lot of money
so vacation was just you know driving an
hour and going to disney world we never
stayed overnight or anything
it was just like one day we'd go like
once every couple of years
and um so i so i still have fond
memories of it from
when i was a kid but you know it's only
a couple rides worth seeing
yeah there's really only a couple good
rides there and they are
as i said they are trying to update
things um to be more in line with like
their newer movies like newer
you know ips and stuff but it's it seems
like it's slow going
they don't really care about that [ __ ]
they're making most of their money off
of things like hotels and merchandise
yeah because they don't really care
about that well because you know
they have all that other [ __ ] too they
have all those hotels around it they
have downtown disney although a lot of
that
you know that's kind of just stores and
everything even though a lot of that
shit's closed now too but
like is that the money you want to go to
universal they got all those marvel
heroes there [ __ ]
girls dressed up as [ __ ] super
[ __ ] heroes and
guys dressed up as superheroes you take
pictures with them better roller
coasters
yeah that's much more geared towards
people
you know like young adults and yeah you
have fun there
yeah we had we we went there when was it
eight years ago
yeah something like that yeah we had fun
yeah we had a good time actually
you're gonna get wet you're gonna get
wet you get wet on half those [ __ ]
rods
yeah um but it's hot here yeah
so nobody minds nobody cares because
it's like yes please spray me with cold
water before i have a heat stroke
all right so uh you you done we cut it
off talking about okay so yeah it's this
we actually went on longer than
everybody's saying hi everybody's here
hi everybody
but yeah so uh anyway like i said this
uh this movie it's called relic it
doesn't have anything to do with
you know the relic that came out in the
1990s about the museum
which i don't i remember that being kind
of cheesy but fun i haven't seen that a
long time this is a totally different
movie so this is a new one
um and like i said if you know if you
dig any of the
movies that i mentioned in comparison
with it then uh you'll probably like
this one as well like
you know nothing earth-shattering but
it's a perfectly enjoyable move not
super long it's only an hour and a half
um and you can rent it on pretty much
all of those streaming
uh platforms that i know of youtube and
whatnot
uh so that'll do it for today's matinee
we'll probably do another one tomorrow
tomorrow we'll probably do another
matinee or
okay sidetracks or something like that
probably about the same time
if i can find a new movie to watch
tonight somebody asked us to do the
house that jack built
which um i had actually been wanting to
see so i don't know maybe i'll watch
that tonight or
some other day and review that floor
sponge right i don't know if you're
gonna like that or not
all right so uh we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow thanks for coming by